story another interest rate hike as
inflation now reaches record highs it is
now the second hike from the federal
reserve in just a few months it has some
nervous for what comes next sasha loftis
joining us in studio tonight with more
on what this means for you denise and
brian this is the latest effort to curb
those high inflation rates but what does
it mean if you're buying or selling a
house i spoke with an expert tonight to
find out today's the first day we've
shown it christopher haraway is selling
his home and he's optimistic about the
future
even as things continue to change i've
owned a couple properties in vegas i
bought them at different times vegas is
always a good market to be in on
wednesday the federal reserve announced
another interest rate hike of three
quarters of a point the second and as
many months it's calming down for a
seller's market and we have a little bit
more inventory don holf of exit realty
number one says these rising numbers are
meant to curb inflation but it can
affect what kind of house you're able to
buy a higher interest rate means a
bigger monthly payment which can require
more money down if somebody qualified
for a five hundred thousand dollar house
at a four percent interest rate let's
say
and it went up to five percent they
would lose about ten to twenty thousand
dollars in buying power but holf says
it's all about perspective another spike
may seem scary but it's still a lot
lower than what we've seen in years past
and the pug agrees with me and
christopher says he'll continue to look
forward
to all our local market has to offer
vegas is going to be fine that doesn't
bother me
the don said it's important to note
these federal interest rate hikes will
affect your credit card student loan and
heloc payments they will also raise car
loan rates denise